[Music]
well greetings friends thank you for
joining us for our question and answer
program I'd like to know this is a a
program where you send us your questions
and of course we do the research and
then answer them
online uh I'd like to give you the
electronic address where you can send
your questions to us you'll see it on
the screen
TVM tv.org once again TVM tv.org
and send them there we'll answer them as
we receive them we'll put them in order
sometimes it'll take uh uh a while for
us to get to your questions but keep on
tuning in because we will uh get to your
question eventually I have with me
Pastor David Salazar good friend and um
very hard worker here at secret Sun
sealed thank you for being with us
Pastor it's always a blessing and a
privilege to share this space and this
program with you praise the Lord you
know we want to have a word of prayer to
start out absolutely uh never should we
open the pages of the Bible without
prayer so please pray for us absolutely
let's pray heavenly father as we come
before you at this hour power we thank
you for giving us the opportunity to
study your word and for the freedom that
we have still that we can share from
your word the truth and we thank you for
the friends who have sent their
questions I know that they're sending
them seeking your wisdom your answers
and so we pray that we can be used by
your holy spirit so that the words and
the answers we give will bring them the
answer from you and I pray this in Jesus
name amen amen
okay we have a very practical question
Pastor Salasar to start out today uh
it's somewhat lengthy uh it comes from
Tesha and uh I just want to read it
because it presents a kind of a dire
scenario in in her life uh good morning
afternoon pastors I have a question
concerning the best way to tackle the
debts I have I am up to my eyeballs in
debt student loans credit cards colle
ction accounts Jesus tells us to owe no
one anything except love and I'm aware
of the councils from the spirit of
Prophecy concerning debt this is causing
me so much anxiety because I simply
don't make enough to deal with it my
apartment lease is getting ready to
expire and I'm seriously considering
just living in my car until my debts are
paid off which if I did would take a
minimum of of 3 years or more I have
been Faithfully returning tithes and
offerings on every penny I receive since
joining the church in
2017 but the debts are growing with
interest every year and considering my
level of debt is it wise to continue
giving offerings so the big question is
should I cut off my offerings in order
to pay my debts I don't think that the
tithe is negotiable I think she makes
clear that she's tithing Faithfully but
uh should she maybe streamline her
offerings so so what kind of counsel can
we give to the this uh dear lady well
Pastor the first thing is from the Bible
we know that in Malachi chapter 3 verse
8 it's actually when the question is
asked you know will a man rob God and
the answer is yet ye have robbed me for
you say where have we robbed thee in
ties and offer and offerings so God thus
look at offerings as non-negotiable as
the same as ties now offering is a
offering of free will the time the
amount the the the number is something
that you are elected to choose usually
the idea is that if God gave you a base
of 10% in Tiding your offering should be
about the same that's sort of what what
is sort of expected but since there is
not a defined line we are not going to
dictate you know what should be what
number should be However the fact is not
giving offerings to the Lord is part of
robbing God as long with the T and
offering so so I I think that that's the
main you know the first thing to say now
in regards to what to do in this
contition because she's definitely I
mean I feel for her she's in up to her
eyeballs in debt student loans credit
cards collection accounts I mean
it's it's it's it's terrible however
from my experience I can say this I know
what it feels to go through that
experience I know what it means to have
gone or been in that situation but as
long as we decide to put God's test and
you know first and Bible speaks of first
of all here it says you know test me now
prove me God says in this part as long
as we decide to do that faithfulness of
of giving God our tithes and offerings
there is that assurance that God will
start opening and blessing us in ways
that we cannot even think of now
specifically what can she do today to
fix this situation I think that one of
the first things that she needs some
Financial advice Pastor I think she
needs to seek Financial advice now um
maybe there's someone in her church
maybe the treasurer there depending on
the treasure obviously we don't know not
everybody has the same skills but maybe
there's someone in the church that has
the skills to give her financial advice
and she could go to maybe one of those
consolidated debt programs that there
are available sometimes there's this
these agencies that are allowed you or
give you the flexibility to consolidate
all your debts into one payment and
these are things that you can use that I
think are important but I think she
needs guidance that's what I would
recommend you know going to financial
advice hopefully someone in the church
church or someone in her family that
knows how to manage but it required from
her restraint it requires restraint it
requires real learning maybe she needs
to look for a you know a more um
suitable place to live more affordable
but God can open the doors God can open
the door as she's faithful to touch the
you know the the heart of someone who
will give her a better you know place or
a lower amount of money for for for rent
so these are things that God can do but
I believe her May first things let me
follow the Lord's advice and not Rob him
you know God in that passage that you
read from Malachi uh says that if we are
faithful in our tithes and offerings
that he will pour out a blessing that we
will have not enough room to receive uh
however there are other parts in the
Bible that tell us that uh if we don't
manage the rest of our money wisely MH
it doesn't mean that returning tithes
and offerings we're going to receive the
blessing that we think think we're going
to receive cor because because God also
tells us to get out of debt MH uh now
the situation that I that I read here uh
of Tesha uh is that probably she has not
been careful in the manage of management
of her funds and she's gotten into this
difficult situation because of money
mismanagement so first of all I would
say return your tithe and offerings like
you mentioned Malachi says tithe and
offerings right be continue to be
faithful in that get yourself someone
from the church or a financial
management uh
organization that can consolidate your
debts and then you can pay a little uh a
little it'll take you probably a longer
period of time but eventually you can
eliminate the debts now the problem is
if you consolidate your debts and then
you continue getting a debt yeah they
make the point it becom a very very
serious thing so you have to pray and
ask the Lord for self-discipline mhm
pray that the Lord will provide the
funds for for you to be able to handle
your debts and uh continue to be
faithful in tithe and offerings and God
promises that if you do those two things
restraint and also faithfulness to God
God is going to bless and you're going
to be able to get out of debt don't be
desperate and think that it's going to
happen overnight you mentioned here
three years well if it takes three years
or six years you just have to make up
your mind that you're going to do it and
mainly exercise restraint that's my
point exercise restraint be faithful to
God and make sure that you manage your
funds very carefully
judiciously and I think God is going to
uh help uh her get out of debt and you
know debt is a heavy load I know because
when I was going to Andrew University
when I was going to school you know
you're dirt poor at that time you were
and and I would go to the you know there
was a store called gold
blats University and that store had so
many good stuff you know and we would
buy stuff and buy stuff and uh we got
into debt and it's just like a heavy
load on on your head and on your
shoulders you're always worried not only
about studying you're worrying also
about how you're going to pay off your
debts you know whether they're going to
come and confiscate and so you want to
be out of debt you feel so much Freer
you know Pastor in in along the lines
and I think it's important just to give
an Evidence you know it's it's so
important that we feel the need to
restrain to learn to cultivate ways of
being Frugal with what we have and be
you know following the the counsel and I
believe that God can give us the the
knowledge and understanding to do these
things in a way where we don't have to
spend money that we don't have uh just
to give you a quick example I was
needing a vehicle for my family and you
know nowadays is very common to uh to
get in debt to go to buy a car and I
said to the Lord and I told my wife you
know I don't want to be in debt I want
to be able to pay have a car and I don't
need to have a new car you know there's
no need to buy new cars we don't have
that kind of income for that because
people today are spending so much money
in new cars and I said Lord you need to
give me something that we can pay off
that we don't have to have any debt and
and I asked the Lord for something
specific like like it had to cover my
wife when she heard the the what was
required she said that's impossible I
said Lord honey the Lord if it's his
will we can get it she she called it
Trifecta you know had to be cheap had to
be newer had to have low mileage Etc and
God Pastor I can tell you this God
answered I mean had to wait and just
have to have patience and patience and
you know we have to spend several months
uh to be able to get that and the Lord
provided us so I believe that God can
answer you and you know you if you are
impulsed to buy something right away if
you are impulsed to you know like you
said uh get the latest technology buy
the you know buy something that appeals
to you without you having that restraint
you're not learning the lessons of
responsibility with financial uh with
the things that the Lord has given you
so we have to make that decision early
before we continue or start this journey
amen so well I hope that the council has
been um you know helpful uh we feel for
you we've been down that road yeah I'm
not on that road right now praise the
Lord because of the counsel that I've uh
given and that you have given but um
hopefully Tessa you'll be able to get
out of debt and uh be able to sleep amen
because I'll tell you when you have that
worry it's very difficult okay so what's
our next question the next question
Pastor comes to us from Roland and is a
question from Australia and he ask
question is to you actually and says
Dear Pastor bour according to Le
Leviticus
165 the blood of the sacrifice for the
sins of the people is sprinkled upon The
Mercy Seat each year on the day of
atonement now the question is when did
the blood of Christ find its way upon
the mercy seat for
us okay it's a very very good question
um and uh we need to look at the concept
of blood in the
sanctuary the first uh point is that the
blood was shed mhm in the court it was
shed in the court right of the sanctuary
the court of course represents the Cross
of Christ so the shedding of the blood
that makes provision for salvation for
anyone who claims it mhm is offered in
the court yes but then the priest would
take the blood into the holy place the
holy place and they would sprinkle the
blood on the veil and in that way the
the sin was transferred through the
blood that was shed right into the
sanctuary mhm in other words The Sinner
could go home and sing redeemed how I
love to Proclaim it yeah yeah you know
he was cleansed from sin but now the
sanctuary was defiled correct so you
know there's this question does does uh
blood defile or does it cleanse you know
the blood there are texts in the Bible
that say that the blood defiles it
defiles the sanctuary when it's
transferred into the sanctuary that's
but it but it cleanses the individual
The Sinner right but that's not all the
story the blood is shed on the cross
that same blood
is is presented by Christ m in the Holy
Place throughout the Christian
dispensation to transfer the sin through
the intercession of Christ into the
sanctuary yeah and now the question here
is the mercy seat on the day of
atonement the purpose of of of
sprinkling The Blood On The Mercy Seat
was to cleanse the sanctuary correct
through the blood from sin mhm and so
there's three different functions of the
blood yes the first function of the
blood is to shed it so it's it's
available it's accessible the second
function is when you claim it Christ
intercedes presents his blood in your
place the third aspect of the blood is
when the blood cleanses the sanctuary
from the record of sin that entered into
the sanctuary uh so uh but when was the
blood shed it was shed when Jesus died
on the cross mhm so the blood of his
offering on the day of atonement is the
blood that he shed on the cross exactly
that doesn't mean that the that the day
of atonement took place at the cross
because that's the argument that Desmond
Ford used he says well you know the
blood was sprinkled on the day of
atonement uh did Jesus have to die all
over again on the day of atonement he
said no uh the blood that it that
cleanses the sanctuary is the blood that
he shed on the cross so his argument was
that the cross was the day of atonement
but that misguided of course the blood
that is offered then becomes useful MH
to intercede and useful to cleanse the
sanctuary but it's the same blood and
this is you know proven in Hebrews
chapter 10 well through throughout the
Book of Hebrews but CH chapter 10 of
Hebrews really mentions how the blood of
Christ is the perfect blood that was
sacrificed and another thing that it's
uh that you know that is important is
that UL ultimately Pastor the blood in
the in the in the um Tabernacle system
we know that that blood is also used to
uh cast if you will the ultimately guilt
upon the uh goat that was chosen in the
day of atonement to take away the guilt
ultimately for all the sins which was a
representation of Satan so in other
words in a sense that ultimately the the
casting lots of the uh of that day of
atonement that blood signifying that it
was going to be um
given as cleans in the sanctuary but
also in that day the guilt of the of the
sin was placed on ultimately on the goat
that was represented of Satan so in the
end of time when Christ
comes notice that he comes with a
garment dipped in blood as well so it is
sort of continuing showing that the
blood of Christ I mean is a symbol of
his blood obviously it's is a symbol
that ultimately he comes also to execute
vengeance upon the you know the those
are rejected rejected and exactly and to
place the ultimate blame upon Satan who
is the author of sin so this is why the
process of the blood of Christ it's a
process that doesn't necessarily ends in
the day of atonement but continues
through the the end so and the important
point is MHM that the cross is Central
because the cross provides the blood
amen exactly for all the other stages
exactly but we should we shouldn't get
all caught up and say well because blood
was offered on the day of atonement the
day of atonement was at the cross yeah
what like Desmond Ford did okay very
good uh we have another question I think
we can get through this one in the time
constraints that we have this question
is from G Gonzalez mhm uh does say where
it comes from but I think we've had this
question before but just in case let's
say a few things about it okay good
day can you please elaborate first John
5:116 And1 17 if you look for that and
read it in a moment what is that sin
that is not unto death I looked at
concordance and one meaning for that
word is sin is mistake sin by mistake
but there are discussions that say these
verses talk about unpardonable sin
versus pardonable Sin praying for your
blessed Ministry I have been blessed so
much thank you so what do we understand
uh concerning that sin that is not unto
death which means that there is a sin
unto death yeah well let's read first
I'll read first uh in John 1 John
chapter 5 and verse
16 through 18 and that's where he
mentions there he says if any man see
his brother sin a sin which is not unto
death he shall ask and he shall give him
life for them that sin not unto death
there is a sin unto death I do not say
that he shall pray for it all
unrighteousness is sin and there is a
sin not unto death we know that
whosoever is born of God sinth not but
he that is begotten of God seeketh
himself and that Wicked one toucheth him
not so um there's this verse here that
it seems to imply that there is two
types of sin in a sense one that is not
unto death and one that is unto
death the we know that everybody has
sinned we all have come to the short
glory of God so we all have sinned we
all have committed sin and we all need
to be cleansed from that sin and so the
Council of John is to those who know
that if we love someone if we know that
the brothers are are in an experience of
yeah you know living a life and they are
in a sin or they're H having issues we
have to pray for them encourage them to
overcome to give up that sin but now if
someone is in this sin that is unto
death which is in a sense the sin that
cannot be pardoned because only one sin
that cannot be pardoned is the one that
is and to death and in that sense I do
believe this is more clearly according
to what he says you know it's the
pardonable sin versus the unpardonable
sin there's that if we know somebody
that is that has rejected the light and
is
so how you say this uh you know so fit
into continually going before the
against the Lord that individual we
don't need to necessarily consider
ourselves that we need to pray for that
and I give an example for example uh
let's say that you were living a time of
or we're living in a time when there's
certain individuals in life and I I
think this is maybe extreme example but
you know some people have said I've
heard even Adventist say you know uh why
don't we pray for the pope you know for
the pope we need to pray for the Pope
that the Lord forgives him you know and
that he can come to the light and it
would wouldn't it be wonderful that you
know the pope turns around and brings
everybody to the knowledge of
Truth when you say that you are a in a
sense absolutely thinking that we are to
you know pray for someone like that who
has unfortunately we know that a person
that gets to that power has already
received has had access to light and has
systematically ried it so praying for
somebody like that is not something that
the Christian need to do I don't think
there is a call for us to be praying for
somebody like that it's like again an
extreme example but I'm just saying
praying for somebody like that it's not
necessarily important and I know some
people might not like this answer but
it's a truth however we are to pray for
those that are near us those that are
you know continually in in in in this
struggle with sin this is what you know
I think that's more important than
trying to pray for individuals who we
don't know of that we don't know if they
had committed imperal sin and it's
better for us to emphasize we got to
pray for those that are near us those
that are friends to
us uh you know Ellen White has described
uh the sin that has no forgiveness MH it
is a sin that is unrepented of mhm as
long as the as long as the Holy Spirit
leads a person to truly repent of
sin and to confess their sin and to feel
sorrow for their sin and to trust in the
merits of Christ's
righteousness that person can have the
Assurance of forgiveness that person's
sin is not a sin unto
death but a person who tries to justify
the sin based on the weakness of human
nature like many people are doing
uh that that don't truly have repentance
sorrow for sin they're afraid of the
consequences but not of the sin itself
MH that they don't repent of they don't
confess that sin is unto death because
Christ can do nothing for a person like
that and so I do believe that this uh in
first John is referring to the
unpardonable sin which is shutting down
to the voice of the Holy Spirit yeah and
sins yes mistakes that we make moments
of weakness Etc that when we do it we
say man I blew it I'm so sorry did this
yet this led Jesus to the cross of
Calvary I'm so sorry Lord that I
offended you uh I confess my sin I don't
deserve anything but but please Lord
take your righteousness and put it to to
my account at that moment that's not a
sin unto death because Jesus has taken
it upon himself yeah and so I believe
that that is what uh what John is
writing here in uh 1 John uh chapter 5
amen well uh it's been a very engaging
interesting conversation today uh we
love these questions um but our time is
just about up thank you so much for
sending your questions thank you so much
for tuning in may God bless you and keep
you in his care and keep the questions
coming we hope to see you as well in our
next program I'd like to know blessings
to all of you
[Music]